THIS IS HIS EIHERE'S TRAVIS KA
TPHEBGT
NET.
HAMMERS AWAY AND SCORES.
>> Steve: HE HAD THE FIRST
OPPORTUNITY THEN THERE TO CLEARS
TO THE AMOUNT OF ENERGY THAT
COLUMBUS IS SUPPOSED TO PLAY
WITH.
YOU WANT TO
LEAVE.
AND THERE'WERENSO,SCORES.
THE FIRST AILABLE.
HE FINDS CATES.
AND FINDS ON THE STARTS TO HEAD.
ATKINS LOOKING TO OUT TO YORK.
YORK HOLDS.
AND HAYES WILL SEND AND COULD N
GET IT.
PETE BACK Jim: THERE'S HAYES.
AND IT'SOVER HEAD LOOK
RIGHT THERE.
VANRIEMSDY GOAL AND MAKES THE
BALL THERE.
>> Jim:AND MANEUVERS UP.
AND HE'S ON TOS  TO HAYES.
AND THE ZONE.
HE WILL CENTER IT.
THE.IDE.
VORACEK FIRST TO IT.
AND LOSES IT THOUGH.
AND NOW KTRIK LAINE
GETS HIT OVER THE LEGS OF CARTER
HART.
HART WITH  AT THE OTHER END.
NO MATTER